hey everybody this one will be
relatively short
uh today i was laid off from my job
it was a layoff official reason was
because of
having to cut expenses internally
due to uh hits to the business from
kova19
so um i filed for unemployment i'm going
through
all the stuff that you know all that
but i did kind of want to make a formal
note here
kind of just to see what happens which i
don't know
i feel a little bit weird about this but
if
you want to help there are a number of
ways that you can do it there's
obviously
the patreon um which is
going to be even more important than it
already was um
simply put what i pull in between
youtube
and patreon is about half of what i need
to make annually
to cover all my expenses
so you know if i
can get that to where it is i won't need
to find other work
i am going to start looking um
regardless
but you know the the x factor is whether
or not
i can find something that will be
accommodating
to this the way my previous job was in
other words
an office monday through friday nine to
five which i may not get i may be stuck
with something with more variable hours
or that includes weekends
which is has the potential to disrupt
the channels if you're not able to
support on patreon there are absolutely
other things that you can do
there's sharing the videos there's just
engaging with them liking
commenting subscribing if you haven't i
have my other channels which
aren't both monetized as well that's
break room of geeks and vera wild being
subscribed to
all three watching videos as they come
out honestly that alone
will help in a way
so for the time being
i'm gonna be splitting my day between
job hunting and
working on this and uh and editing the
book
so uh we'll see
where things go from here in the
wonderful amazing
dream world of my mind i
am able to hold on long enough to pull
things together to get
either my expenses uh down
or and or my revenue up to where i don't
need to find
another job but i'm not
i'm not there right now i'm about
halfway there
so there you go
there will be a live stream tonight 7
p.m eastern time
uh on the day this goes up and i will
you know i'll be more open talking about
uh specifics related to my job and my
plans and
where things will hopefully go and uh
and
yeah we move on from there thanks for
listening
i probably should have structured this a
little bit better probably could have
been a minute if i hadn't rambled my way
through it but thanks all the same
see you around